[Musique]
mes enfants dans quelques instants vous
allez entrer en classe
alors je voudrais d'abord vous poser une
question est ce que vous avez dans la
vie un héros favori doit par exemple
ravageur et l'inspecteur bourrel c'était
ton héros favoris et maintenant on
guérit la fraude est pourquoi au parce
qu'il est fort tu accueilles échanger
bourrel contre thierry et toi tu es ce
que tu as héros favoris oui et il sa
série l'affrontement d'hier ils
affrontent également à tous les héros
mon bonhomme ivanhoé d'ivanhoe tu
préfères ivanova thierry la fronde
pourquoi ce qui met la question nouveau
coup dur prix ils sont beaucoup de pays
c'est la queen anne la loi a battu pour
la manière forte juin voilà c'est toi
femme chanel paris sa femme fait rien
elle
franck fernandel oui il va faire deux
fils oui parce qu'ils en deviennent
c'est aussi rire et et toi ce que tu as
longtemps rue pasteur master et pour
quelle raison parce qu'il a sauvé des
vies humaines
les néophytes
la belle maman baird parce que ses rives
laurel hardy et bien voilà qui est
magnifique l'aurait lire dieu parce que
tu aimes bien rien mais tu as raison
une demoiselle y at-il dans la vie une
personne que vous admirez plus
particulièrement notre foi le soir
claude françois et pourquoi pas ce que
je laime vous l'aimez affaire de coeur
ça ne se discute pas bon aussi géniale
idée géniale idée vous avez une raison
facile à la dizaine
parce que ses idoles des jeunes et en
même temps votre idole chesnin scheller
la scachap du bien et très dynamique sur
scène mais en dehors en dehors des
chanteurs en dehors des artistes est ce
que vous avez une préférence confirmé
cyril attendant le considère comme comme
un artiste si vous voulez vous noyez
personnes un grand médecin grands
savants nous y sommes merci
[Musique]